[Music]
this is a puzzle box how would you solve
it let me show
[Music]
you meet Kagan sound a
multi-award-winning woodworker and
artist who has mastered the craft of
Designing and fabricating intricate
wooden puzzle boxes there's one I made
that was a 5,000 move box but it took so
many moves it would just wear itself out
before you could really open it
successfully you could open it a few
times but the wood Parts would just wear
out with no Nails just carefully
interlaced wood and some glue King can
build eye-catching riddles that are true
challenge to solve this is the Hedgehog
is currently locked this is how you
unlock it each piece has essentially a
notch and a slider underneath they block
each other until they're moved out of
the way so every time I move a piece
it's unlocking the next piece to move
which unlocks the next piece my favorite
feature of this is actually not all the
sliding moves but the way that the lid
comes off by twisting I find that really
surprising and really satisfying it has
a sort of tension to it that's really
beautiful this box is called the hex
flex and this is how you unlock it this
is a box that I really pushed the
boundaries on the material in an
absolutely insane Direction the box was
in the international puzzle party design
competition it took both top Awards
therefore making it the puzzle of the
Year 2023 so not only is it an amazing
puzzle it's an amazing box and each of
these puzzles begins its life in kagan's
home wood shop this is my woodworking
space I've been here for 6 years overall
I've been a woodworker for 20 years I
have a math degree but as far as
woodworking is concerned I'm entirely
self-taught of that all the tools over
in this area for processing the wood and
breaking it down into smaller and
smaller
[Music]
bits over here I'm usually testing out
finishes a lot of times if I can
determine a finish for a particular kind
of wood it will unlock a project in
itself moving over here we have one of
the current projects underway it's
called The Bookmark box and in order to
solve it you actually have to find just
the right spot to push to pop out a
bookmark and then it's used actually to
unlock the Box itself so as the work
flows over in this direction here these
are tools for cutting little miniature
tracks and miniature notches into the
working parts as the Box comes together
I start to grab more and more hand tools
to do the fine-tuning of the piece and
then the main stage where everything's
taking place in a project really is my
workbench here as this piece comes
together it'll look something like this
which has a final finish on it and
functions as a puzzle box this box is
called the plus box I named it after the
pattern of pluses on the top that I
created out of two different colors of
wood the clicking mechanism is created
entirely by wooden
parts
[Music]
it has an actual wooden spring that
clicks into little
notches I have an example of the wooden
spring in a mechanism that rotates but
accomplishes the same thing the spring
is this little chunk of wood in here
with little notches cut in it and it
will click when it hits this Notch area
here and really all it is is just a
piece of wood with a few lines cut into
it from opposing directions and it has a
springy quality to it so that's the same
spring that's inside of this box in
multiple places kagan's newest creation
the cafe wallbox is in process in his
Workshop ready to be actualized I have
the four basic walls of what will become
my puzzle box I've now put in a very
thick big saw blade that's going to cut
notches into the wood and The Notches
are going to create the joinery that
holds together those two rectangles and
creates the corner edge of these boxes
this cut will need to be at an angle so
that I can make what's called a dovetail
track it's a shape of a trapezoid and
that has the function of housing a
slider that's also a trapezoid it won't
be able to pop out it's a sliding part
and it will stay attached to the box but
have the ability to go back and forth so
that was just one side of each of the
trapezoid notches I'm going to cut the
other side of that same Notch now now
what I'm going to do is take these
little pieces of wood with my notches
and use this tool called the router to
to remove all the material in between
these two little notches I
made after Machining notches into these
pieces of wood I now have a dovetail
track after Machining I I'll have to
come around with a chisel to trim
leftover fuzzy material or parts that
the machine couldn't get to and make it
a clean precise dovetail
track this kind of detailed woodworking
is a true passion for Kagan but his love
of puzzles began long before he was
building with wood I had always loved
puzzles but when I first saw a puzzle
box it was a whole another level of
Interest the first ones I ever made I
was in Middle School and I didn't even
have wood I had cardboard it was just a
box that had a move to open but you
couldn't see it it was a very secretive
sliding lid box so I carried that
thought with me all the way to college
and then just was dying to create this
out of wood I I'm almost more proud of
myself for just getting myself into a
place to build that box it represents a
lot to me a lot more than just building
it was the path of finding the tools and
the passion of wanting that designed to
be a real thing to solve the pin wheel
box this is working entirely on a
principle in Puzzles called coordinate
motion you have more than one moving
part and they all move into each other
in such a way that they also move out of
the way of each other so each of these
panels that's rectangular has a diagonal
movement that goes towards the other so
this panel right here wants to move
diagonally towards this and then this
one moves diagonally towards that and
when they all move diagonally at the
same time it allows them to shift in a
simultaneous dance together this is the
Rune Cube it's locked and this is how
you solve
[Music]
it all right going getting
stuck there we go that's what I
missed I am getting
stumped I have that
correct this
is there are some puzzles I have that it
would take me a while to unlock and this
would qualify as one of
those there we go so as I'm designing
these puzzle boxes it a lot of it is
just contemplative I'm just sitting
thinking about how these things move in
my head I really don't get too carried
away drawing it in detail I mostly just
do very rough sketches sometimes a
sequence of moves but I keep it very
loose in order to give myself
flexibility because the designs really
change a lot something like the the cafe
wall pattern shifting illusion actually
came out of woodworking where I was
creating a piece of inlay and I was
moving little parts around to make this
inlay block and then I noticed oh they
can turn into other patterns but what's
amazing is it's made up of five strips
of wood and the strips are really
actually quite simple in comparison to
what the pattern is so with the Box lid
there's two of these sliders that change
patterns and what I like to do with a
lot of my puzzles is to have someone
who's opening the box be required to
actually create
different patterns along the way of
solving it making patterns starts from
two different colors of wood and these
Woods I take and I glue them and I stack
them all together and after they're
they're glued up I take this block and I
then machine out uh angled rectangular
blocks these blocks are then arranged
into striped pattern and these will then
get glued together after the pattern's
created I I take a wet sponge I can wet
the top of that wood a little bit just
has it effect of making the wood more
pliable for a
plane and then iron it to flatten it out
and I now have a veneer and I'll just
glue this down onto a strip of cherry so
this turns from here into here this side
has the top and there's two notches cut
on each side here and the top will then
slide in just like this in order to
force someone to actually solve these
different patterns it requires that each
of these sliders is attached to a little
Peg and that the peg then has to go and
navigate through a maze so I've made
this lid that goes underneath it and it
will register each of the sliders and
have make it so you have to progress
through the patterns to unlock it so
that sits in here I've prepared a box
and finished it for this particular box
I opted to start with a different
pattern and have it transform into the
pattern you saw before as like the other
one that side slides down you would then
slide the pattern and that would be the
opening of that box the maze plate is
itself just push on it to pop it up and
I can you can see the inside of the box
as hard to solve as some of kagan's
puzzles are he encouraged me to try and
figure out one for myself okay this
moves you're doing the right thing by
Looking For What needs to move that's
what it's all about oh no I'm stuck
backwards oh this is so fun yeah this is
essentially a maze but made out of
rectangles so you are currently in the
Maze oh I just went
backwards I think I did that one already
getting lost in a maze is a big part of
solving puzzle box and remembering where
you were recognizing new passages big
part of the fun uh oh I got stuck again
so this is a little psychological it
might have tricked you into thinking you
didn't make any progress but I would
encourage you to keep going forward on
those tiles you've actually accomplished
a lot you've changed the state of those
tiles they're now rearranged so if
things are rearranged that could mean
something different can happen oh so
maybe I can like push it
oh so that wasn't allowed to happen
before that's a new
thing oh that's so cool yeah when you're
playing with a puzzle box you just
always are paying attention to how
things change and it might be very
subtle and it might make you think you
aren't making any progress but you
really are as long as you keep exploring
you'll eventually get it open it's
really cool I'm hooked and I want to do
like six
more it's really fun so this box is
called the snake box I took the blockbox
concept a little bit further and used
rectangles that I made out of two
different colors of wood right now it's
tessellation that I really like that I
refer to as snakes and what it does is
by Shifting the uh blocks around on it
it transforms into an entirely new
pattern that's very identifiable if this
pattern is created then you've solved
the box and you can open it up no matter
how many boxes Kagan builds or attempts
his love for puzzles only continues to
grow I think people love mechanical
puzzles because there's a playfulness to
it it's reminding us to be a child and
to interact with something in a tactile
way but also be thoughtful and curious
about the object to me the best puzzles
are the ones that you can play with for
an hour and then you can hand it over to
your 5-year-old and they can look at it
and solve it in 5 minutes I think
children are just inherently good puzzle
solvers and they're also inherently good
at creative projects they're inherently
good at just anything that everyone
wants to be and I think that's really
what gets in people's way when they're
trying to solve a puzzle they almost are
forgetting that they're still a child
there's a child inside of them that's
still
there